Soon the Galaxy will be remade
the Jedi
and Republic
will die.
I sense a plot to destroy the
Jedi
great care we must take
why would anyone walk away from being a
Jedi
we were trained to be keepers of the peace.
not soldiers
we clones
have mixed feelings about the war
without it we wouldn't exist
All part of the plan
THE plan.
everything is about to change
every choice made
has led to this
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my star wars the clone wars
season 7 trailer in Easter eggs for the
mandalorian series so season 1 they
revealed a whole bunch of flashbacks and
scenes referencing a bunch of events
from the Clone Wars we're going to see that
play out during these Clone Wars
episodes if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the easter
egg videos I'm also doing Mandalorian
season 2 videos while we wait for
episodes to get here they're almost done
filming that as you can see all the
episodes will start airing on February
21st that's a Friday so each new episode
presumably will drop on Fridays but I
don't know exactly what the episode
schedule is going to be if they're going to
double up on episodes or if it's going to na
be one episode at a time the trailer
starts with the Darth Maul narration I
know a lot of you are confused if you
never watch the Clone Wars series I'll
try to explain what's going on but he
survived being chopped in half by
obi-wan Kenobi during Phantom Menace
then came back at the beginning of Star
Wars the Clone Wars animated series and
they explained in the first couple of
seasons what happens to him how he comes
back to power but the events of this
trailer are taking place right after
he's united all the biggest crime
syndicates in the galaxy taken over the
planet Mandalore using his crime
syndicate power then the very last thing
that we saw from him is that he was
seemingly killed or hurt very badly by
the Emperor it seemed like he was trying
to kill him but obviously we know who
survives because we know later in his
timeline he actually showed up to fight
an older version of obi-wan Kenobi right
before the events of a new hope on
Tatooine and that's where obi-wan Kenobi
kills him for the final time but it's a
much older version of obi-wan Kenobi in
a much older version of Darth Maul
there's a big gap in his timeline
between what happens during the Clone
Wars and when he winds up dying before a
new hope he becomes this really big
figure in the underworld of the Galaxy
head of crimson dawn crime syndicate
we saw him show up during that solo end
credits scene so that period will
actually be covered in the live-action
obi-wan Kenobi Disney Plus series I'll
talk more about that when we get more
details about what's going on with that
series there's actually a couple moments
in the trailer that make me think that
they're actually going to overlap with some
of the events of Revenge of the Sith
like order 66 but I'll get to that in a
second in his voiceover dialogue he
talks about the galaxy being remade the
fall of the Republic the fall of the
Jedi that's probably because he finds
out what the Emperor's long term
plans about order 66 are in even if he
doesn't know exactly what the plans are
he probably just senses that the emperor
has a secret plan to kill the Jedi using
the clones like here you see him using
the dark side of the force to tear into
Clone Trooper Jesse's head jesse was one
of the troopers that actually started to
go crazy and figured out that there was
a control chip in his head and they
almost found out what the emperor's
secret plans were so some of the clones
are a little bit different and they do
sense that something is wrong there's
some programming deep within them buried
that's going to cause them to kill the
Jedi there's a shot at Bogut and Crees
witnessing the siege of Mandalore on
Mandalore she's the younger sister of
Duchess Satine who was a longtime love
interest of obi-wan Kenobi the siege
itself is going to play out over the course
of the 12 episodes that you see in this
trailer
I believe it's 12 episodes for season 7
here's where we start to get to the
Mandalorian crossover moments so during
the Mandalorian episode 8 Moff Gideon
reveals he knows all about them and
knows the Mandalorians real name is din
Joran the information about that was
only stored in the archives on Mandalore
during the Clone Wars
so the Mandalorian said he was taken
there by the Death Watch Mandalorian
after they rescued him as a foundling
and inducted him into their order so the
Mandalorian character would still be a
young boy while this scene is happening
but he was on Mandalore while this was
happening
Moff Gideon was here too because it's
actually the Republic that's laying
siege to Mandalore so that's how he was
here for all this stuff he came later
during the great purge so the great
purge that they kept referring to in the
Mandalore in season 1 is a separate
event from the siege of Mandalore the
reason why the Republic is laying siege
to Mandalore is to get rid of Darth Maul
who controls the planet with the crime
syndicates they're trying to liberate
Mandalore from him in ahsoka is a big
part of that like she comes back to the
Republic she left the Jedi Order during
season 5 so technically she's not a Jedi
anymore but she comes back and she helps
them liberate Mandalore because it seems
like her big arc this season is having
this giant faceoff final battle with
Darth Maul kicking him off the planet
now we know both of them don't die
because Darth Maul is killed by obi-wan
Kenobi many years later in ahsoka is
still alive after the events of Return
of the Jedi I know you're all hoping
that a live-action version of ahsoka
shows up on the Mandalorian in a future
season she be in her early 40s when the
Mandalorians
is happening but she is still alive
after the events of Return of the Jedi
as shown in this scene here from Star
Wars rebels the really cool Easter Egg
here is that when she comes back to the
Republic to help them liberate Mandalore
they give her a company of her own clone
troopers and they paint their helmets to
look like her face that's why they had
the orange helmets this is also clone
trooper Rex working with her they have a
big reunion later during Star Wars
rebels so even though it seems like Rex
is really badly hurt here he does
survive the battle after they do
liberate the planet though they give
control of it to boca tank ruiz but
that's before the great purge you don't
see him wilting the dark saber during
this trailer fight with ahsoka but he
does escape the planet eventually once
he's beaten with the dark saber and it
winds up on Dathomir for many years
until it winds up being recovered by
Sabine Wren during the events of Star
Wars rebels a couple years before a new
hope then she gives it to Bo Catan Crees
then the next time we see at Moff Gideon
has it at the end of Mandalorian Episode
eight so presumably he took it from
Bogut and Crees during the great purge
that happened after the events of what
you're seeing on this series here and I
know I said din Joran the Mandalorian
character was still a youngling training
with the Mandalorians on Mandalore while
this was happening we might see him show
up in the episodes we might see a
younger version of Mothe Gideon show up
during the episodes baby Yoda would be
in his early 20s when this was all going
on so without more flashbacks for
context I'm assuming based on what they
told us during the events of the
Mandalorian series that he's at this
point still in hiding in the Outer Rim
territories being protected by people
that'll lure it to the Jedi and loyal to
Yoda there's a bunch of shots from the
bad batch unfinished episode which it
looks like they've sort of incorporated
into these new episodes there's an
actual unfinished episode where it deals
with a bunch of clone troopers that are
quote-unquote defective and realized
they're different but they have
different abilities than the regular
clones they're just way more badass big
easter egg here you'll notice this is a
young version of Kanan Jara's from Star
Wars rebels with his master when he was
still a Padawan mace windu repeats one
of his lines of dialogue from Revenge of
the Sith and then ahsoka repeats one of
his lines of dialogue from attack of the
clones there's a really big scene
foreshadowing his turn to the dark side
during Revenge of the Sith here he's
getting ready to kill the separatist
commanders this is Admiral
French Admiral trench has died several
times in the show he's one of the more
evil commanders and was also responsible
for a lot of the programming for order
66 into the clones so he's behind a lot
of this bigger plot to kill the Jedi -
this really low shot of him igniting his
lightsaber getting ready to kill him is
made to look exactly the same as this
shot of him igniting it to kill the
young links during Revenge of the Sith
you also notice that Anakin Skywalker's
hair is much longer in these scenes
closer to what it looked like during
Revenge of the Sith and here's a really
big crossover a moment with Revenge of
this said people are wondering about
because it seemingly breaks the timeline
if it's not from the events of Revenge
of the Sith you see him speaking with a
hologram of a very visibly pregnant
Padme and a lot of people have been
talking about this because it seemingly
breaks continuity because we don't know
when it takes place in the timeline we
know that Anakin didn't learn Padme was
pregnant till the events of Revenge of
the Sith she tells him Anakin I'm
pregnant he gets really happy so maybe
he's either just totally oblivious to
her giant stomach or maybe he thinks she
ate a really big lunch or this is
happening during Revenge of the Sith and
we'll see order 66 play out during the
Clone Wars episodes this is ahsoka on
the obadiah moon that's the headquarters
the pike crime syndicate they have deep
ties to Darth Maul like I said the big
battle of this season is going to be a
Ahsoka versus Darth Maul they're really
hyping that up in the trailer footage so
if you haven't spent a lot of time
watching Clone Wars episodes before as
long as you loosely remember the events
of Revenge of the Sith you'll be able to
follow what's happening here because
this will explain a lot of what happens
during the Mandalorian series on Disney
Plus and give you a lot more context for
what was happening in and around Revenge
of the Sith like right at the end of
last season we actually learned how Yoda
learned to become a force ghost and how
he eventually wound up teaching obi-wan
Kenobi how to become a force ghost so
like I said there'll be a lot of
crossover moments with the Mandalorian
live-action series so I'll point those
out whenever I do easter-egg videos
first episode obviously not dropping til
the third week in February so I'll just
remind people when we get closer let me
know in the comments have you spotted
any big Easter eggs that I didn't
mention in the video this is the way and
they just made a big announcement about
the plot for the Mandalorian season 2
and baby Yoda you can click here to
learn about that and click here for all
my Mandalorian episode videos
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I have spoken!